the opening celebration of the new tan
yang Center
MIT the new center was created based on
our skiff from hak-kan and lisa yang who
are committed to a better understanding
of autism and improving our treatment
options autism is now known to be
characterized by a spectrum of behaviors
ranging from severely affected
individuals with intellectual
disabilities who may be confined
institutions to individuals who may be
considered socially different from some
points of view who are probably well
represented on our faculty here at MIT
the goal of research in the new center
is to give people on the autism spectrum
and their families better options in the
future than they have today now those of
you who are familiar with autism know
that there already exists traditional
funding sources for autism research most
notably the NIH for I spent seven years
heading the NIH intramural program in
Bethesda my former boss Steve Hyman the
director former director of the NIH is
here today Steve spent time and service
as Provost at MIT and is now head of the
the Stanley Center where's one of our
closest collaborators the problem with
traditional funding agencies is that
funding is so tight that they become
very conservative it's a human nature in
most cases funding their research their
funds on research that's already been
done and to avoid any possibility of
failure there's also little funding to
support groups of scientists working
together on important problems
now while NIH funding continues to be
the lifeblood of biomedical research the
major shortcoming is that were simply
not making progress fast enough we need
to take more risks in our research and
pursue new directions that may not work
out but may give us the breakthrough
that we desperately need we as
scientists also need to work together as
a team collaborating not only within the
here at MIT and Harvard but with
scientists around the world because the
problems of autism are bigger than
anyone's going to solve working in their
own lab this will be the philosophy of
the new Center we will take advantage of
the tremendous new opportunities created
by CRISPR the revolutionary gene editing
technology developed by Fung Jeong who
you'll be hearing from today Fung John
will head up our efforts to use CRISPR
for all new approaches in gene therapy
and autism from clapping Fung you'll
hear about our program to create new
primate genetic models of autism using
CRISPR in a program that we believe is
unique in the world
Gloria choy will tell us about a new
program to explore the role of the
immune system in brain development and
autism which builds on her stunning new
results published in science last year
and John Gabrieli will tell us about the
state-of-the-art and human brain imaging
to study autism in the Imaging Center
this located just below us here in this
building I want to end by thanking Lisa
and Hawk we will work hard to realize
their dream of progress and autism
research it's a dream that's shared by
Lori McGovern and the late Pat McGovern
who invested in the McGovern Institute
because they believe that neuroscience
will help mankind let's make it happen I
would now like to introduce Bob Maillard
a strong supporter of neuroscience and
the chair of the MIT corporation
thank thanks Bob
good evening this good crowd for a warm
evening as you all know we're here to
celebrate Hawk and lisas tremendous gift
to to help catalyze autism research i've
personally gotten to know both of them
independently over the past year or so
and and i was so impressed with him I
dragged them up to my wife and who's
here with me now so thank you all for
coming was especially thank you to my
wife as as you all probably know I don't
think anybody on earth doesn't know that
MIT is in the middle of a substantive
campaign and that campaign is called
campaign to make a better world which is
not a slogan it's it's a reality because
most of you most of you really know MIT
in a profound way and if nothing else
MIT has has really dedicated itself to
to real-world problem solving and has
solved a lot of those problems and one
of the real pillars of that campaign is
is human health and and brain science
and its associated diseases is is really
an important vector for mi t--'s work
and it brings together a huge amount of
strengths from diverse fields because if
someone said to me at a cocktail there
is no silver bullet for for for for
brain disorders and so just up to my
head the things we that really come
together in this building or cognitive
science neuroscience biology obviously
basic science engineering computation
even neuro economics I mean there's just
you know in true true form MIT just
fuses a
huge number of its capabilities and and
and and probably no more no no in no
place more than in brain science which
probably is the most complicated science
anybody in humanity has ever ever ever
attempted and in Kendall Square which is
which is what this is part of we bring
to get not only the different
capabilities at MIT but the capabilities
of associated institutions the broad
Harvard Mass General the whole ecosystem
of Kendall Square biotechnology finance
the hospitals did I say that apparently
more than 50% of MIT faculty are
involved in life science research in one
form or another and a lot of it is a lot
of it is is his brain and neuroscience
related so thank you again Lisa and Hawk
for this it's really this tremendous
gift there are so many people in this
room and among our friends whose lives
have been touched by by things that we
really can can can can help do something
about let me lower you you're going to
speak glory harp McGovern who co-founded
the McGovern Institute one of the
pillars of mi t--'s creating cognitive
science vectors and and the McGovern
Institute is where the where the
Tennessee that the Tang yeah that's a
tongue twister the Tang Yanks Center
will will actually reside so Lori
glory well thanks for the nice
introduction the big plug for MIT at
large as well I know
the campaign is in its midst and height
and as chairman of the corporation it's
your duty so I get that but thanks for
the nice comments and Bob thank you for
your nice comments but I also would like
to tell everybody that both Bob and
Bethany are celebrating a special day
today Bob DeSimone birthday and Bob in
Bethany's anniversary so congratulations
well and I couldn't be more pleased than
to have a chance to say a few words as
well and greet you Lisa and Hawk and
your family your son Nick his wife
Meredith was actually expecting a little
bit a baby and Eva their daughter many
of your friends and colleagues lots of
members of the McGovern Institute and
the MIT family at large skull thank you
all for being here
you know sometimes serendipitous
meetings can really create magic and I'm
going to tie this a little bit more just
towards talk and Lisa rather than
talking about all the great things we'll
be doing here because Bob addressed
already very well but it's because of
that serendipitous meeting that the
magic of the 10 yang or yang 10 Center
is the cause for all coming together
into celebration I really still remember
so vividly when I met Hawk through Tony
son and as he just corrected me I
thought it was at the Asian Art Museum
but actually it was at the World Court
Hotel on Sand Hill Road for some MIT
function and so on Tony's phone came
opposite Lori no how kind of come over
here I've gotta meet Lori McGovern and
so we we met we chatted we talked about
brain Institute and decided to meet for
a get acquaintance breakfast
getting to know your breakfast which we
did on March 5th at 7:30 at Baywatch is
a crummy little coffee shop you wanted
to go to something fancier that I'm not
driving let's go to this little coffee
shop so that's where we met for about
two hours in s then segue into meeting
you Lisa your daughter Eva and Hawk
every coffee shop at the airport in San
Francisco because it was the only place
where we could meet I just come back
from Europe the day before you were in
Napa and we said well how about before
you fly out so here we were at Pete's
coffee shop in in in San Francisco well
if the name implies you know Pete's
coffee sells coffee and it's called
intensely bold and flavorful flavorful
smoky overtones with a pleasant bite and
I thought that was actually appropriate
and so I thought let's share the best I
simply call it's not like having a board
board or nose I simply call it unique
strong and energized energizing and that
copy helped us into a unique and strong
and highly energetic conversation which
we started that fateful morning and when
I met you Lisa I knew exactly who you
were how you're going to operate that
you were ready to dive in discover and
you reminded me so much of pattern me
when we looked at establishing the
McGovern Institute and where we were
going to place in it it was very
reminiscent and from the beginning you
also understood that we were not talking
about how can you give $100,000 to a lab
I think I made it very clear you know
let's discuss the center because of your
own unique circumstances of your ability
to do so and be kind of I think we laid
that out pretty quickly so when we had
all those parameters fed because really
discuss how we were going to you know
structure and build the center
that you so graciously funded and then I
also remember you are calling me at 6
a.m. from the East Coast you did it for
you it was nine it was but you know you
were still in a California mode because
Hawk doesn't look too far from where I
live called me from the from the East
Coast to let me know that you are ready
to find the contract and it was
Christmas Eve and I went yes yes I was
just beyond excited you're almost
apologized for having taken so long and
you know to you know forgive you for
having just bought Broadcom for six
point seven billion dollars and
integration into a smaller company took
a little bit of time so I think that was
it was absolutely the best you know
present to find the Christmas and
arrived it was Christmas Eve with all of
you don't believe in Christmas there is
a Santa Claus
and you can call me you can call me at
any time a day with that kind of good
news so Lisa and her how can Lisa you
know I just want you to know how
thrilled I am to be able to thank you
publicly you know for what you have done
and how much you believed in the mission
of the McGovern Institute what we are
trying to achieve here in through the
generosity of funding this institute
give our scientists the ability to help
in advance research into the underlying
mechanisms of autism in the end to the
process and cover the mystery that
underlies it
you know I want you to know the
businessman because you always will get
oh I you know and I told you I think
very quickly it's not buying company
where you [ __ ] the bad assets and then
assemble you know the good ones and then
repurpose them this is not like the trip
business this has no shelf life so the
ROI that you will have is going to be
infinite with our discoveries okay so
anyway let the journey continue and
accelerate with the addition of the ten
yang Center and ladies and gentlemen I'm
going to be very
formal now I couldn't be more proud than
to present Lisa and talk
Lisa yang and half-10 and Bob would you
join me please to give a little present
that we have for you and could you
please come up because it would give you
a little gift of appreciation and it is
self right yes but they're from actually
a notice on my model nose
yeah the nomination right this is a
mouse not a good mom yes and yeah thank
you very much
I'd like to introduce what would like to
speak for it I go first
okay my name go are just kidding and
that's a reason why about such an
elegant let you understand oh no you go
ahead
oh okay oh yeah yeah okay no human no no
like I pokiman right right okay Laurie
Laurie Bob Bob again you know since I've
been here last and last several years
mit has really profoundly improved we
got great salespeople now okay listening
to the three of your great great
speeches anyway seriously distinguished
faculty MIT McGovern Institute
researchers friends family we're very
very appreciative today that you join us
to celebrate this event this launch of
the Center for autism research we really
touched to for many of many people we
see here in the audience who came from
very far away just to be here with us
appreciated very much
and in interest of full disclosure -
since Laurie is letting it all hang out
Lisa and I had half of severely autistic
son he's now 31 years old but I can just
I can still remember the very soak we
can see remember vividly we kind of
figured something was not quite right
probably 28 years ago 29 years ago and
didn't know we were living in Singapore
then he was born in Singapore so we
tripped we pull him and trips to
multiple places we went to Australia
some other places before I remember Hong
Kong perhaps
finally we came to Philadelphia I
remember Philadelphia Children's
Hospital when we kind of got a dime
final diagnosis from that he was he is
very autistic so that's all good and
fine but what followed soon was okay how
do you give care to that such to him
really it's all about coping parents
family siblings scoping okay and that
pretty much they took up all right a lot
of my attention in in terms of what we
do next
we even haul stakes I'm from Singapore
and move to Philadelphia certain topic
and it was interesting and I let Lisa
fill you in more on the details of what
it takes as I'm sure some of you do know
thank you for sharing that in developed
a very severely autistic child it's not
all negative by the way because my 31
year old today is like a bit unlike my
boy it's pretty good doesn't grow up yes
I like that's a lot of fun but but it
was a buddy was all about coping coping
coping and not in a negative sense but
it is is about care and we know a lot of
funds that come out from government
private sector and he has a lot of good
care a lot of care that could be better
and it's about dealing with a person but
more recently two years ago to be exact
as Laurie said arraigned the lorry I
talked to Lisa and she connected with
Laurie to and the McGovern Institute and
from through Laurie Bob DeSimone go pain
thing John it's called Boyden and a lot
of others and we start to dare to hope
we start to dare to dream and the dream
was simply there for us
selfishly or potentially for others
that we could like you find a cure or
enable if you're not as finding kill and
enable support a cure for autism enhance
the genesis of this give this Center for
autism research we hope this will do
something as you say Laurie nan in the
next one year two years five years in it
a long time and we certainly appreciate
your joining us here to celebrate that I
[Applause]
hear a lot of familiar faces and I'm so
grateful that people have come from afar
as well as locally to support what I see
is a very important venture for us it's
not just it may not be hope for just a
family because it may not happen in our
children's lifetime but I think we need
to bring hope to the future for
individuals on the autism spectrum I
actually want to express not usually in
society but I want to express that I'm
very impressed with the vision of Pat
who is not with us anymore and Laurie
McGovern to set up the McGovern
Institute for brain research I'm very
impressed with the way Laurie you know
if we were the whip right so and that's
why we finally decided this is where we
want to have the home for autism
research
I'm very impressed on a very personal
level she has been an incredible beacon
of an example and inspiration and I hope
that I can precipitate change as
effectively and as timely and as
tirelessly as she can
so I'm very grateful I'm very grateful
to her family Liz I know is here and
you know and I know Michelle can join us
today but I'm very happy that her family
has continued to be involved and will
continue to be involved
so as Hawk said if this is a very
personal thing if I don't have any
children with autism I probably wouldn't
even be aware of this but I have seen
how debilitating this disorder can be
whether it's high functioning
individuals or and because it's a
spectrum disorder it goes all the way to
individuals that are very severely
impacted they have a lot of physical
issues stimuli can affect them
differently and intellectually as well
as the ability to function in society
because it's difficulty to read social
cues and I want to call out one
individual in the audience Jose Velasco
when you Jose Oh Jose Velasco runs the
autism at work program at si P and this
is the third fourth going to fourth year
of a seven year pilot where si P I said
that they want to have 1% of the global
workforce or they're running about
85,000 now yeah to be firmed on from the
spectrum so I feel that and we were in
Palo Alto for a and autism at work
conference and si P organized it ASAP
Labs in Palo Alto Microsoft was there HP
IBM was interested for Towers Watson HP
Australia so we have these companies
that are stepping up because you know
we're not talking about our children who
may not be able to function in society
or kept at home or they playing video
games or reading anime we're talking
about you know these are every
individual deserves the right and the
ability to be able to work because
that's where they form a social network
where they have a purpose in life and I
think they develop and I look at these
individuals as they mature they will
grow up and they were acquire different
abilities so one of the things I want to
leave behind because I know we are
really on a very short time line here do
not give up hope
and when you look at families that have
children with autism if they're very
young and their Tantrums
be more compassionate and try to
understand what the families are going
through but the siblings are going
through so that's all I can say and I'm
very hopeful and thankful that we can
house is in Laurie some Institute
[Applause]